>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> John Kelly: Wouldn't you like
to be reincarnated as a taste bud
on Calvin Trillin's tongue?
His books "American
Fried", "Alice Let's Eat"
and "Third Helping" the
so-called tummy trilogy recount
in wonderful detail meals
he has eaten both the good
and less frequently the bad.
In our family, we still
quote one of his essays
in which he quoted a daughter
dismissing inferior bagels
as round bread.
That's not a bagel.
That's just round bread.
Calvin Trillin is the
[inaudible] of pleasure, I think,
not in any fussy overly
aesthetic way
but in the honest pleasure
that's to be found in a stack
of barbecued ribs or a decent
honest bagel or fresh corn,
or as in his novel,
"Temper Isn't Going Out.
The Pleasure of the
Perfect Parking Spot."
I love what Wikipedia had to say
about Temper Isn't Going Out.
It said, " It is unusual
among novels
for exploring the subject
of parking."
I did not look to see if the
Melville entry in Wikipedia said,
"It is unusual among novels for
exploring the subject of whales."
Calvin Trillin started out as
a journalist at Time Magazine.
His first piece is in The New
Yorker about desegregation
at the University of Georgia
were published in 1963.
He's been appearing regularly
in its pages ever since.
In the summer of 1990
prompted by the sound
of John Sununu's last
name, he wrote the first
of a series of short poems.
"If you knew what Sununu knew."
I wonder what politician's last
name would be worthy of parody now.
That was in the nation
and he continues
to skew our nations politics and
culture in verse on deadline.
In 2012, Calvin Trillin received the
Thurber Prize for American Humor.
He once said, "I actually think of
being funny as an odd turn of mind.
Like a mild disability.
Some weird way of looking at the
world that you can't get rid of."
Aren't we glad that you're disabled.
His new book is called "No Fair.
No Fair. And Other Jolly
Poems of Childhood."
It is illustrated by his New
Yorker accomplice Roz Chast.
His poems now are often very
short in The Nation so I'm going
to keep the rest of this
introduction very short.
Welcome all.
Let's have a ball as we start
chilling with Calvin Trillin.
[ Applause ]
>> Calvin Trillin: Thank you.
Thank you John.
Can you hear me?
I told John not to --
it was not necessary
to have some complicated
introduction.
Just something simple like not since
Mark Twain or something like that.
If I seem in a cheerier mood than a
lot of people here and less nervous
about the election, it's because
I already have a house in Canada.
[ Laughter ]
Let me make a couple of corrections
to that lovely introduction
or things that John left out.
We think that "Temper Isn't Going
Out" is the first parking novel ever
written, and I'd also like
to say about the poetry,
I get paid $100 a poem no
matter how long the poem is.
So, if I write a short poem
which is why I write short poems,
I'm the highest paid poet
in the United States.
Most poets get paid by the line.
So, if I want to get the
buzz you get from working
at the absolute top
dollar in your field,
I just write even a four line poem.
Like in 2008 election I
wrote one about Mitt Romney.
Yes, Mitt is smooth of speech
and smooth of [inaudible].
Reminds us all of Ken,
of Ken and Barbie.
So quick to shed his
moderate regalia.
He may like Ken be
lacking genitalia.
[ Laughter ]
The origin of this book, "No Fair.
No Fair" is my life experience,
partly with my grandchildren,
partly with my children, and
partly when I was growing
up with an older sister
known as Suki, the oppressor.
The idea of doing it in poetry
started when my youngest grandson,
Netty, was slow in getting dressed.
He was about seven and his mother
said, "Netty, put your pants on,"
and I found myself saying
or actually singing.
I won't trouble you
with the singing.
"Oh, this is such a silly rule that
people must wear pants to school.
A better rule a wise man said was
wear your underpants instead."
And that sort of started
me on the idea
of writing a book about
childhood really.
But as I say, part of it was
from my own experience
with Suki the oppressor.
We used to share the
backseat on long trips.
I lived in Kansas City which the
real estate people would call
equally convenient to either
coast, and my father thought
that we should see the country.
So, we took long motor
trips when we were children
and we shared the backseat and
there was an invisible line
down the middle of the backseat.
At least she said it was the
middle and there was a lot
of tension around that line.
I compared it to the
tension between countries.
Say between the Soviet
Union and Finland.
I played Finland.
Then my father said something
that I think he meant well
but he had old fashioned values.
He said, "We do not hit girls.
You will never hit
your sister again."
Suki was not visited with
a similar injunction.
So, I became a unilaterally
disarmed Finland.
My father meanwhile was pointing
out the Buicks and the [inaudible].
I think now if I hadn't had to stay
on a constant alert from a sister
with expansionist backseat policies,
I would now know the difference
between a Buick and a [inaudible].
There's also a poem in here
-- so there's a poem about --
it's called "The Backseat" in here.
There's another poem that's
called "To Get A Pet."
Children have different
ideas of pets.
Those of you who are
parents know this
and again I harken
it to my childhood.
We had a collie puppy named Chubby
and Chubby was quite sickly.
And then one day, Chubby was
gone and we said to our parents,
"Where's Chubby," and they
said, "Well, Chubby --
we have friends who have a farm.
We thought Chubby would be happier
and healthier in the farm frolicking
in the barn yard with
the other animals."
I didn't think much of
it and I didn't think
about Chubby for a long time.
Then I was home from college
and Chubby's name was brought up
and I said, "Why didn't we ever
go visit Chubby at the farm?"
Suki said, "There wasn't
any farm you dummy.
Chubby had to be put down,"
and I said, "Chubby's gone?"
My mother said, "He'd
be gone in any case.
Collies don't usually
live 18 or 20 years."
I said, "Why am I just
hearing about it now?"
My father said, "It's not our
fault you're slow on the uptake."
[ Laughter ]
Then about a week or so
after I wrote about Chubby
in some place, I got
a call from Suki.
She said the collie
was not called Chubby.
The Collie was called George.
"You were called Chubby."
There's another poem about
somebody who asked the same question
of children he meets, a
kind of ice-breaker question
which as it happens, I
asked children just to sort
of break the ice if I'm left
alone with a kid, I say,
"Who's the nastiest awfullest
meanest kid in your whole class?"
You'd be surprised how
often the answer is Jason.
I'm not quite sure why but those
of you who are about to have a baby
and are thinking of names
ought to think about that.
And there's a poem about trying
to send back a baby here.
That is from the best
story I ever heard
about older children
responding to the birth
of a new child was some people I
know who had a three-year-old boy
and then they had another
little boy.
Everything seemed fine
for about six weeks
and then the three-year-old walked
into their bedroom one morning
and said, "I think this would be
a good day to send Brandon back
to his real mommy and daddy."
So, that's in this story and
there's some stuff about fantasy
in this story that
I fantasize about.
There's a story about a little
boy who eats everything.
One of the lines is,
"His tum it seems
at times was nearly bottomless.
His dad said Matt would
eat a hippotamus,"
and I think that's sort
of a wish fulfillment.
I had two girls and one of
them was a very picky eater.
Particularly, I had troubles
getting her to eat vegetables.
And one day my wife made the most
elaborate concoction out of spinach.
World famous chefs would have
fainted at eating this spinach
and we asked her to
test the spinach.
She took what I use to
call one of her micro-bites
and then we all waited for her
opinion and she said, "Well,
it's better than a carrot."
We found that a very
valuable phrase to use.
Sometimes we'd see a movie and say,
"Well, it's better than a carrot,"
and sometimes we'd
see a movie and say,
"Not quite as good as a carrot."
And I think some of
the poems are a fantasy
of my vengeance on
Suki the oppressor.
I mean, Suki's very nice now.
Well --
[ Laughter ]
-- I once upon Suki's request, no,
I'll say upon Suki's order dedicated
a book to her and I showed it
to my wife and said, "What do you
think about this as a dedication?"
And it said, "To my sister Suki Fox
and a first tentative step toward
forgiving her for trying to throw me
down the laundry chute in 1937."
My wife said I couldn't
use the laundry chute part.
I said, "Why not?"
She said, "It's not gracious."
I said, "Attempted
murder is not gracious."
Suki recently had a big birthday and
we sent her a tape and I started it
by saying, "Well, you're
80 now Suki.
It occurred to me it might
be an appropriate time for me
to forgive you once and for
all for trying to throw me
down the laundry chute in 1937."
But then I thought, there's time.
[ Laughter ]
I'd like to read one
of the fantasy poems.
This one's about a
sister named Jenny.
Jenny's a better rhyme than Suki.
I have to get my glasses on first.
This book is illustrated
by the way, as you heard,
by Roz Chast, who is
simply a genius.
She sort of makes the book.
This poem is called -- I'm
not sure I can see here.
Excuse me.
Let me -- this book is called
"Could Jenny Get This Shot For Me?
I've Done So Much For Her."
This was actually inspired by one
of my nephews who when he was taken
to the doctor for a shot, when they
parked the car said to his mom,
"Maybe you should get this for me.
I'll just wait in the car."
I know the shot will guard me
from the measles and the mumps.
Diseases that could leave me with
two different kinds of lumps.
I'm glad the stuff that's in the
shot will keep me safe from harm
but can't they put the needle
into someone else's arm?
If so, my older sister
is the person I'd prefer.
Could Jenny get this shot for me?
I've done so much for her.
He once read her a fairy tale
she loved and ever since,
she's thought a certain frog if
kissed would turn into a prince.
Remember what I did for her?
I'm sure you didn't miss it.
I threw my pet frog in her lap
and then I said, "So, kiss it."
That frog was only one of
many favors that there were.
Could Jenny get this shot for me?
I've done so much for her.
Once Jenny on a summer day
was in her party clothes
and seeing just how hot she
was, I sprayed her with a hose.
Once noticing how much the
same her dollies all appeared,
I gave one doll a different
look by drawing on a beard.
She has to be so grateful
for my favors.
There have been many.
So, could she get this shot for me?
I've done so much for Jenny.
[ Applause ]
Well, I'm sure that's given you
meat for many profound questions.
I've just wrecked the stage.
So, if anybody has any
questions, step to the microphone.
There's a question.
Oh, no, there's just a look.
Questions?
There's a question.
>> Just wondering as the
grandson of a bagel baker,
once you get out of New York City,
do you have a favorite
place for bagels?
>> Calvin Trillin: Well, you heard
the quote from my daughter Abigail
when she was four that
in Kansas City,
bagels taste just like round bread.
I remember doing a column once on
a new finding in emergency rooms,
not in New York but out in the
country where people cut themselves
on trying to slice frozen bagels out
in what I call the bagel barrens.
And, of course, there
wasn't any problem,
and one of the New York
emergency room doctors said,
"Some of those places are just
ethnically unprepared for bagels."
But I like Montreal Bagels.
They're sort of sweet, and I
just read a story that somebody
in Cincinnati is trying to make
very good bagels but it's difficult.
And of course, everybody says it's
the water in New York and they say
that about the pizza too.
So, I don't know.
I think it's just old-fashioned
preparation.
The bagel place near me was started
by a German-Irish guy from Queens
who sold to the people who ran the
pizza parlor next door who were
of course from the Middle East
and their bagels were rolled
out at night by Thais.
The Thais have taken over the
bagel ruling from the Dominicans.
Yes, ma'am?
>> Hi. I love you first of all.
>> Calvin Trillin: Oh, chucks.
Chucks.
[ Laughter ]
>> I remember reading
"Alice Let's Eat" lying
on the living room sofa
literally falling off
because I was laughing so hard.
And my question --
>> Calvin Trillin: Oh, by the way,
I'm not liable for any of that.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> Calvin Trillin:
That's not actionable.
We've checked this before.
>> No lawsuits.
The three writers who make me
laugh out loud are P.G. Wodehouse,
E.F. Benson, and Calvin
Trillin, and I'm wondering
who makes you laugh
when you read them?
Laugh out loud?
>> Calvin Trillin: I'm
not much of a laugher.
>> I never would have guessed.
>> Calvin Trillin: But
I think a lot of people,
Dave Perry used to make me laugh.
He sort of quit writing.
Kind of turned to the
more lucrative area
of young adult books and things.
Although he just wrote
a book about Florida.
I used to laugh a lot at a writer
who was considered sort
of low-brow I think.
It was Max Shulman.
I gave one of his books
to my daughter
and he could hear her
laughing in her room.
She was about 14, and I meant to
find out where he was and write him
and say, "It's nice to make
two generations laugh."
I remember actually the
passage where Doby Gillis
which later became a television show
and Doby's mother is saying, "Doby,
you're going off to college
and here I am no smarter
than your hound dog Fred over
in the corner playing dead."
And he says, "Watch how
you talk about Fred, mom."
She said, "Look at him
playing dead over there."
She says, "Doby, I meant to tell you
Sarah liked that as much as I did."
Thank you.
>> Thanks.
>> I love the way you have those
reminisces about the rivalries.
I'm in the middle of seven kids
and you've got me thinking a lot
about stuff that is
still to be forgiven.
But what I'm not hearing is
your sister's perspective.
What would she say in
retort to some of the --
>> Calvin Trillin: I'm sorry.
I couldn't hear you.
Could you say it again?
>> What is your sister's
-- that's what happened.
Okay.
>> Calvin Trillin: No, no, go ahead.
I really didn't hear you.
>> Well, seriously then, what would
be your sister's retort to some
of the liabilest things
you're saying about her?
>> Calvin Trillin: Well,
the laundry chute incident,
the attempted murder
incident is very easy.
She told one of my
daughters I was too fat
to fit down the laundry chute.
And then, I don't know.
I would say that on the incursion
on my side of the front seat,
I would say if you read
what Vladimir Putin says
about the Ukraine, you get
pretty much what Suki would say.
>> Thank you.
>> I also love you and [inaudible].
For those of us who can't make
your New Yorker tour of Chinatown,
do you have any recommendations
there?
>> Calvin Trillin: Well,
a lot of places are good.
The real Chinese food freaks
go to Queens or Brooklyn now,
but I live about an eight or nine
minute bike ride to Chinatown
so I tend to still go to Chinatown.
One of the places we stop
at [inaudible] Restaurant
where we stop on the tour.
It's really kind of a walk --
snacking walk, is Xi'an's
Famous Food
which has something I love called
a spicy lamb and cumin sandwich.
Sometimes when I go to
Chinatown I just pick up things.
Like there's a place called Super
Taste which I found when I stopped
on my bike because I saw
what I thought was one
of the best restaurant names
I have seen in New York,
New City Fish Balls, and it
turned out that there are a lot
of hand-pulled noodle
places on Eldrige Street
and the one I would go to is
Super Taste, and I get a bag
of frozen dumplings, 50 for $9.00,
and I put them in the freezer
because I've seen those movies where
the Apaches attack and you can't go
out and I dump them in
boiling water and I'm done.
>> Thank you.
>> You asked me who
the most annoying kid
in my class was and I said Michael.
What advice can you give me
for annoying kids like Michael?
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>> Calvin Trillin: You don't have
any organized crime connections,
I guess.
This is Theo who suffered -- that's
right, your name is Theo, right?
>> Yes.
>> Calvin Trillin: Yes.
She has suffered from Michael.
How's your right-hand punch?
Your hook?
Not good?
>> No.
>> Calvin Trillin: In
that case, I'd snitch.
[ Laughter ]
I would tell the teacher.
Get rid of that kid.
>> Thank you.
>> Calvin Trillin: Or have
him change his name to Jason.
>> You write extensively about
parking in New York City,
and I'm wondering how you feel about
Uber now using driverless cars.
Would you be comfortable
in a driverless car?
>> Calvin Trillin: I don't think I'm
quite ready for a driverless car,
and parking is difficult
in certain neighborhoods.
And then I keep my car in a garage.
I used to do the alternate
side parking thing
but I heard somebody say in New
York about alternate side parking.
You can either have a car or a job.
It takes up your life and
a lot of people are afraid
to move their cars once
they get a good spot.
And [inaudible], I think
there was a passage
where that was how this young
man rated the young women he met.
Was she worth moving the
car for out of the spot
that was good for tomorrow?
>> Thank you.
>> First I want to thank you for
many hours of enjoyable reading.
I used to live in Kansas City so I
was wondering what you missed most
about Kansas City if anything.
>> Calvin Trillin: Well,
everything, and I don't doubt
that you live there but I have to
say a lot of people claim to be
from Kansas who aren't
just for the prestige.
>> I really am from Kansas City.
>> Calvin Trillin:
I'm glad to hear that.
I miss everything.
Thank you.
I think we're done.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.